[Music]
anyone anyone know who that is who is
she sweet innocent young lady hold on no
is that i justine who's i justine she
was a youtuber oh she's a youtuber oh
gee youtube right
youtuber yeah sure i don't know what she
is no she makes content she does yeah
what kind of why do you have a weird
smirk underneath dude i'm not swearing
at all only fans
oh she's probably a really famous only
fans girl her name is mia malkova that
sounds really familiar malcova is she a
tennis player she's a pornography star
she is a porn star oh wow i'm surprised
i didn't know i'm surprised you didn't
either
you didn't know well because i got away
from the name like like the name brand
one oh so you just write colors you just
write colors when you do your switches
no like i'm more of like a connoisseur
like uh like i like to support
in like influencers oh i like like
talking to patrol
she's not tucked up gonna say i like to
support my people's pixelated uh ones
yeah that too oh yeah his peoples yeah
that doesn't make sense but when we're
born here we have privates you can see
when you're born over there everyone's
could you imagine the kid if you're born
over there and that's all you see is
pixels
the first time you see it like that's
what it looks like
you're worried about your own because
it's not pixelated
where's all the squares what are those
squares mine has hair on it so this is a
porn star mia malkova recounts the
weirdest sex requests she's ever
received oh yes like like in person like
at a convention or like through comments
or
let's go and just uh work out our
creative brains real quick what's like a
weird sex request that maybe sitting on
balloons definitely gets me hard i like
when chicks sit on balloons like and
they pop i like it when they pop but
like when they crush those balloons big
time i like it when a chick sits on a
balloon and she kind of like get looks
at the camera surprise while it pops
kind of enjoy that a lot whoa
you are creative what about uh they
asked her to put a caterpillar and a
[ __ ] and a butterfly to come out oh
that's pretty weird then you have to
spend two weeks with her
that's pretty weird i'm going for the
full metamorphosis dude that's pretty
that's pretty creative
they want to see her quilt a blanket
oh
not sexual at all wow that's weird right
that's a weird thing like naked at least
mine went to some [ __ ] up places just
record the blanket okay
well why did you guys stop like where's
where else in your mind i thought she
was crocheting her [ __ ] here
and i'm ashamed to say is that what it
is you have to look at your face like i
can't believe you no i'm just i'm just i
love the
quilt a blanket out of her [ __ ] hair
that's what i thought that's unique
that's what i'm saying that was like a
collab over there no that's what it is
that's what's in the story so oh yeah i
don't know a weird one weird one would
be like um hey like have sex with me
and my dad and my brother
yeah yeah one my mom watches what my mom
watches while my mom watches my mom
films it especially if she doesn't do
like that family genre either oh yeah
true true true because if she does it is
normal
[Laughter]
and then that's what we don't want in
porn we don't want normal yeah now so
having worked in the porn industry for
many years becoming one of its biggest
stars miyamotova has seen a lot and with
over 10.5 million followers on instagram
she clearly has a lot of fans and
admirers who have followed her career
over the years
the adult entertainer appeared on a
podcast recently to talk all about her
profession and some of the strange
going-ons that come with it and one
particularly weird sex request stood out
in her memory this was an interesting
guy he couldn't get hard unless you
kicked him in the balls
and i kicked him hard she explained
that's not that weird we heard so many
[ __ ] things on the uh were they like
penis mutilation but if they kick me in
the balls i can't get hard yeah what do
you have to do that too i wouldn't
realize that the pain of of getting
kicked i like to think i would rise
above but i know myself
that is true because when you get kicked
on the balls how do you get hard because
you get limp oh yeah you fall on the
ground that's training when you start
crying how quickly does he get erect
afterwards it's immediate
is it like he kicks in there
that'd be pretty cool she said i was shy
to kick him and i'm in [ __ ] stilettos
oh so i was being nice at first i kept
looking at him engaging because i didn't
want to hurt him and i was like no i
think he wants it so i kicked him real
hard and i dropped him and he looked up
smiling and he had this dick hard his
dick hard you're right and he said thank
you
that's quick was this like a private
client or was i don't know is that a
show
it's a lot of private jobs
i'm not sure what the scenario or the
space in which this happens maybe he's a
co-star yeah it's like the only way i
can get
but my question would be like for guys
like him is is how do you know
this needs to happen for you to become a
wrestler it's a really good question
that's his baseline the moment of
discovery yeah because like the first
the first time he had sex with a girl
whether in junior high high school
college or whatever
i doubt
she's gonna be like hey can i kick you
in the balls or maybe he watched like a
ufc someone got kicked in the balls and
got hard korean dude that was it joe
chung in the first ufc he kept getting
punched in the balls and he and he was
like what am i gay no what's going on i
don't know but this is amazing yeah it
was getting real hard huh i think it
might have been dude but how do you know
like what's what's the what they call
that marvel the origin story yeah what's
the origin story i mean maybe it's also
one of those random like physical things
where like you have like less nerves or
you don't feel pain so much and so you
have to like start like doing different
things to like test out your like so
like he [ __ ] so much that regular sex
don't turn him on anymore and he's like
nothing works yeah maybe and then one
day it was just kind of like [ __ ] it
like just kick me in the balls yeah but
there's got to be like a you know like
steps towards it
it's probably like when he's trying to
fix like a television device or like a
broken piece of electronics and he's
just like you know you gotta [ __ ] hit
it and so his dick's probably not
working for a while and he's like just
try hitting it we'll see what happens
and then also it's like
you know what i mean then it's like hey
i told you that [ __ ] works and there was
like porn on in the background so
there's an association
there's a lot of guys that like uh in in
s m that like to get their dick smashed
and uh with with some like a girls high
heels or like all these things right
whipped and [ __ ] yeah and i'm like how
did they progress to that yeah because
that's crazy like did it start from just
like regular sex and then that wasn't
good enough and then they needed other
things or did they already have a
dysfunctional dick why are you like
feeling uncomfortable no my stomach it's
not yet through yum you know yeah
because i get it hey because that's why
i have this thing like you know most
guys fantasy is like two girls hundred
percent yeah or three keep a basic yeah
but like for me like if i i talk about
oh yeah i want to do but if it if that
opportunity arose
and and i wasn't sober i'd probably turn
it down and be like you're crazy why you
would not no but this is why though
because now your level of pleasure is
not raised
so then you're not going to have stuff
with two girls all the time you know you
really there's a warner and now when you
have sex with one you're always gonna be
limp all the time exactly you then
you're gonna turn it to the guy that
wants to get his balls kicked it's a
slippery slope dude so don't have
threesomes you can i think your level of
pleasure gets raised well it's like this
though it's like let's say you watch
like the best movie you've ever seen
obviously the next like [ __ ] five ten
maybe even 20 movies suck but eventually
if you watch 20 movies in a row that
suck
your level gets eventually but it's like
it's like drugs or the first time you
were drunk that nothing can replicate
that first time that first high and
that's why i think two girls and what's
next like three girls or
like an extreme example you have sex
with a hot girl and she was amazing and
then after that it's just all medium
girls yeah then it's like hot girls are
a gateway drug i tell you what exactly i
basically [ __ ] dudes now because i [ __ ]
too many
i have a question are they hot dudes are
they hot dudes or whatever the dudes you
know so i guess the advice here is
always start at the bottom of the barrel
just to make sure you got somewhere to
go progress yeah slowly i'm chasing that
[ __ ] high dude yeah because the older
we get i think we've matured and we know
like okay this is a bad pass yeah you
know like i'm sure the guy when he got
he first got kicked in the knee and he
got hard and he's like oh this doesn't
work anymore i'm gonna go keep going up
he should have known he's gonna get to
the balls once yeah what's next you know
maybe he discovered it in boxing because
he would spar with his buddies and every
time he gets punched his dick gets hard
and he goes wait a minute
there's something to this
and jody told me to explore all these
cody's in his ear bro get kicked in the
nuts and you'll get hard cause that is
such a odd
because it's so i mean because the women
out there listening i know you can't
fully empathize with how painful it is
because even the thought of it is super
painful women don't go through much
pains what you're saying i get it yeah i
mean pregnancy whatever try getting
kicked at the balls that's way i mean
but like a good clean shot it hurts so
much for guys that we can't even scream
we fall there's no energy all the energy
goes to the center and we fall
and we want to be mad at the person that
kicked us but we can't sometimes you gag
too dude there was there was a fight
this past weekend and um it was an mma
fight in bellator and there's this
really famous karate [ __ ] yeah yeah
there's a really famous karate
specialist named raymond daniels has one
of the craziest kicks of all time yeah
he has the probably the most powerful
kick is a spinning back fist because
it's a spin plus a like a like a side
kick right
this guy threw a spinning back kick hit
this guy in the balls
and immediately spit out his it was like
the one that was nuts yeah
jizz just comes out his dick was hard
and i'm saying no but he spit out his
mouthpiece and he's screaming
on the map just like
like you know like you've never heard
like you've never heard a nut shot this
hard before and you can hear the heel oh
it's so [ __ ] firefighters wearing a
cup he should have been fine probably
shattered that [ __ ] he probably broke he
probably broke that [ __ ] way that
this guy kicks he [ __ ] spins around
like a tornado and then charges up one
of the best kickers in the world yeah
and he did it
to his digging balls and he goes you can
see the pain you can hear it and it was
just like i couldn't get through the
whole video i couldn't watch it does
that guy have 17 balls now probably
shattered
humpty dumpty balls
it's hamburger helping he gets kicked he
spits out and a butterfly comes out
oh [ __ ] he put the [ __ ] the good news
is you still have your balls the bad
news is you have 17 balls but that's
kind of good news isn't it but there's
little balls of little balls
now you'll ejaculate 17 times
[Music]
[Music]
foreign